guys not for me so
um i want to cover a little bit a little
bit more rogan
this is a dude from curb is he so when
do you get skinny
dude he's late a couple years ago he
lost a lot of weight actually that's
jeff garland yeah man
wow yeah yeah yeah yeah he he loved good
for him by the way he lost wow
he lost a lot of good and and you know
you know how some people
uh there's there's bad weight loss where
you look terrible he look he lost the
weight well
you know he look he looks okay yeah
there's like italian
guys usually are ugly anyway
yeah they can be skinny or fat so he uh
was on joe rogan
and he was talking about the craft
the biz comedy
there's not enough podcasts to do that
there's nothing that's really not
it's not i mean i get enough of that
with ryan long canadian [ __ ]
i love you ryan ah
check this out so somebody did a little
super cut
he's basically making fun of rogue into
his face
you know what up get up no and by the
way
when you see someone moving around like
that on stage i will bet you
every penny i have they're not funny in
the corner of the couch
[Music]
[ __ ] is that the equivalent of a guy
stool [ __ ] there's not a lot of time
has kind of an elitist approach to kami
it's quite interesting he likes bars
he says he likes jokes he doesn't like
stool [ __ ] hmm
when it comes his whole body just erupts
any time i saw someone miming having sex
you know pumping air yeah i would just
go not funny no
no oh no
oh no i love this none of them know
none of them realize do you feel awkward
i feel really awkward right
i feel really awkward right now i feel
really awkward
it was just like it was a sign of like
but what if there's a bit where you have
to mime
pumping pumping air he's defending
oh no he's defending himself no no no no
no no no but hear me out though dude no
no what if like but what if
like you're making it like the stool
is getting [ __ ] no
what then he is
no but hear me out on this what if like
you
you were making it like do you well what
if you made it like the stool was
[ __ ] you
right then it's a new take on it it's a
new spin
no no no no no no no no
oh no this is uncomfortable for a couple
of
reasons
you could tell number one that jeff
carlin is not trying to do this to
insult him i don't think jeff carlin has
just watched any
journey no he is he has no idea what's
going on right that's what i'm saying
none of these people
realize they're doing it they're just
talking to joe rogan
yeah oh yeah it's like it was a sign of
like
but what if there's a bit where you have
to mime pumping
pumping air then you need new bits like
i'm look i've never done stand up so i
admit that i will
but mike you have did you ever have a
bit where you had the mind pumping air
i mean no okay and if you did
i never really did the physical stuff
you weren't a jim carrey type
i never really did the physical stuff we
had a guy that we used to do
that used to do a lot of that stuff his
name was zach and he uh
his bits were all really bad and the
only reason we brought him is because he
was young
good looking and for some reason
whenever we did
any college town this was back when
remember when facebook was like
colleges only and stuff yeah so i
remember around that time where
he could get a lot of girls and a lot of
people to show up
to our our college area gigs
this is the only reason he got the gig
but he did a lot of that stool humping
[Music]
his bits were really poorly thought out
but we used to always
do we used to watch him and just uh
our [ __ ] would clinch
someone goes wait you're not talking
about think cook are you no i wish
i wish with that ding cook hook
still [ __ ] if it's the right bit can
be funny
no i can't no no no
joe no no joey can't joe
it can't be funny buddy
it's it's
just you know for somebody who likes to
impart comedic knowledge to his little
underlings like brendan shop for example
where it's like
man you just got to do this when other
people like other
comedians maybe try to impart knowledge
to him joe won't be humble enough to go
i guess you're right man i guess maybe i
shouldn't [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
stools because i'm 50. really it has to
be the right it has to be
a real comic with a real reason to [ __ ]
that stool
bro you don't get it you don't get the
crap oh he's [ __ ]
civilians you civilians don't you don't
get it because you don't understand the
craft this is high art
this is high art uh remember that time
that george carlin
humped the stool no i said don't okay
but hold on wait hear me out
remember that time richard pryor hump
the stool
no rush no i don't recall time richard
pryor ever did that
one more just because this one i do
remember i remember this remember this
for a fact
remember when bill hicks no was okay
well
i guess i'm wrong there has to be
something to it why do you do that it
looks
dumb all right this is just being gay
that's all
okay and god you know what this video is
pointing out and i didn't put this
together
it's one thing to have one stool [ __ ]
bit
but this is spanning decades of his
career
and it's it's it's it's an art form it's
a lost art
it's not a lost art form it was never an
art some would say it's a genre of
comedy royce
and and some would say no none has
excelled at that genre more than joe
rogan
that's a good point but somebody was
remembering patrice's one of the best
stand-up
specials ever elephant in the room when
he had sex with a stool
no okay sorry yeah that's it it's gotta
be a bit
pumping hair yeah i mean like he's gotta
be screwing up something yeah
some bits what what he's
oh ah painfully watching right now
i'm not even painful watching him defend
this i feel i feel
pins and needles i'm actually cringing
watching him try to defend it instead of
going but you know what again
if he had done one [ __ ] stool humping
bit you would go
yeah i mean i did one like 10 years ago
was prob at the time it was funny
i wouldn't but this is from a newer
special this special that we're looking
at here is a couple years old
this is this isn't like this isn't an
old special
this is rough
but who doesn't know what that that
looks like why do you need to pump maybe
there's a reason
there's got to be something you give the
wreath no no
no no no because joe's still playing
this is just what happened to joe right
now
he's still playing like he's not the guy
that was doing it
he's going to be like you know what if
another comic no no joe
show your work explain your reason for
having to hump
i can't believe i'm saying this this guy
had elon musk on the other day
he [ __ ] had elon musk on
he had a presidential candidate on his
show
can i joe please explain why you have to
hump a stool
i want to know i want to know your
reasoning behind it joe
jamie pull that up
i think the problem with you royce is
yeah
look it's real easy to
to be an armchair quarterback as they
say
and sit there and run your mouth about
something you don't understand
but until you've been on stage
using a tool uh using a stool as sort of
a placeholder
for a person that you're putting your
dick in and writhing around with
i tell you you're joking but i hate that
you're saying that until you've
been it's like it's like you watch
nascar right you go oh man this guy
really sucks but until you've been in
the driver's seat shut up dude i know
you're kidding but
i'm getting mad at you until you suit up
and hit the field how are you gonna sit
there and tell
some other guy he did poorly so next
time you [ __ ] [ __ ] are sitting
there going
actually i heard on rogan you should do
blah blah blah this guy pumps the wolves
these guys are all there's nothing going
on behind the curtain
like these people are famous it's a crap
shoot dude
somebody's nothing fascinating royce
needs to watch fighter and the kid more
often get his head around what real
comedy is
you're right you're right papa you're
right show those calves
just like you're imitating someone
having a heart attack pumping
i'm not that
that's where you're wrong kiddo it looks
[ __ ] stupid
sure does joe it sure does
it looks stupid royce
podcast in the world ladies and
gentlemen biggest podcaster in the world
but like what if you're
really expressing your sexual angst but
you're using a piece of furniture what
if you use words
but like the stool is there yeah but you
have a mouth
use your mouth but then why have a stool
to sit on to put your
you know what a stool this for to sit on
or to put your water off
yeah or your shrink on if you're duck
stand hope that's what it's for
and most of the move around people are
pushing it
just over sell [ __ ] by physicalizing
what should be just funny the way you
say
write that [ __ ] down [ __ ]
what is this one from because this this
one is egregiously bad i'm sure somebody
could tell us can somebody
somebody who knows can you tell us what
special this was it's earlier obviously
because he still has hair in this one
i'm trying to think of eddie [ __ ] this
tool nobody's [ __ ] no stool bro
is that charlemagne
is that charlemagne i don't know uh
somebody in the chat please
somebody will verify that charlotte i'm
pretty sure that charlemagne i don't
remember any [ __ ]
stool dog talking about eddie mur eddie
murphy
yes of course yeah it is it is charlotte
he's actually one of my uh
favorite people all the like it
when it comes to guys that do hip-hop
radio
yeah he is he's a goddamn hero he's the
one that had liar cohen on
i was like talking about how he's just
always pushing dope and [ __ ] robbing
people to black kids
and like he's tread dangerously close to
jq levels at times i love charlemagne is
one of the few dudes i give some props
to
and by the way before you guys go you
don't have the finger on the pulse you
know who charlemagne is you're
forgetting we're racist
it's really important to remember here
see i like eddie i like richard i like
chris rock bless you i like chappelle
you know what i'm saying like i want i
like people that have something to say
all that stool [ __ ] is hanging
these okay these guys have to know like
at this point they have to know right
like this can't be
they they're doing it to mock him to his
face right charlemagne might be because
he's a
he's a prick right he's a real prick i
don't know but i don't know
pro wrestling machine says charlemagne
doesn't fart in his clothes
i would never disrespect the craft like
that well
i'm hurting i'm hurting i'm hurting you
wouldn't have to disrespect it you would
just have to want to do it and then try
it
[Applause]
if the content is about your physicality
right that's not dancing right right
dancing's when you
when you put like english like when you
when you're doing this to accentuate
what you're saying
it's like screw that we don't need that
one more time
i'm not that funny man i need some help
you know sometimes the mask falls off my
couch you know sometimes how that just
mass just comes right off ouch
thank you show up too man shout out to
brendan chob um i really do appreciate
what you do for
for comics though
and then the last frame is this
those sneakers are enraging that's what
he do for comics though
that whole outfit's enraging oh yeah
he's it dresses like a child
he dresses like a just [ __ ] child